Speaker 1: We've just learned that the upcoming
January six Trump Riot Committee hearings,
which start Thursday night in primetime,
will reportedly include video of testimony
from Donald Trump's daughter, Ivanka Trump, and
testimony from Donald Trump's son in law, Ivanka's
husband, Jared Kushner, both key players in the
Trump administration. Now, this may not achieve
anything, but it should serve to shed some serious
light on what took place. We're going to look at
the new report about this. Remember that Jamie
Raskin last week told us we are we are bringing
the heat. We are going to be exposing some
serious things during these committee hearings.
And then there's the question of who will
be watching, but we'll talk about that in
a moment. Huffington Post Report January 6th
panel to reportedly air Ivanka Trump and Jared
Kushner videotapes. The House Select Committee
investigating last year's insurrection is gearing
up for its national debut of hearings that will
include videotaped interviews with Ivanka Trump
and Jared Kushner per The Washington Post.
On Thursday, select committee chair Bennie
Thompson and Vice Chair Liz Cheney will launch the
series of televised hearings featuring both live
witnesses and taped interviews, including several
White House figures. Both Trump and Kushner served
as senior advisers in Donald Trump's White
House during the insurrection last year.
Their interviews have been described to the Post
as gripping. I think we don't have any idea how
insane these hearings are going to be yet. The
committee will attempt to place the violence at
the Capitol on January 6th in a broader context
of a wide ranging scheme to overturn a legitimate
presidential election. With Trump's involvement
serving as the through line, Cassidy Hutchinson,
a top aide to the former White House chief
of staff Mark Meadows, is expected to play
a key role. She's already reportedly provided the
committee with extensive information about Meadows
activities aimed at overturning the election. The
final hearing will focus mainly on Trump, what he
did and what he said before and on January 6th.
Any remaining bombshells will be revealed by then.
This is a very, very big deal. Now,
will anybody be watching these hearings?
I don't know. It's you know, if a 10th of
the adult population were to watch it live,
I'd be surprised. I'm not particularly optimistic
right now that this is going to garner the large
mainstream audience. I think in our world, this
is going to be huge for people who follow shows
like ours. And I want this to break through
into the mainstream. I wish we didn't have
circumstances where lots of people are fine either
having no idea what happens at such a hearing
or being told by Fox News the next day what
took place. Because we can guess that the story
that the mainstream media will tell will be at
best incomplete. And the story that right wing
weaponized media like Fox News, Newsmax and
Oan will tell will be actively deceptive. It
will likely get a lot of media coverage, but
the question is how much interest will there
be from Americans in the hearings themselves?
The primary sources, as I like to call them,
and unfortunately, we have this status quo in
the United States where we've got a lot of this
casually right wing, disinterested Americans who
aren't interested in watching something for hours
but are very happy to be told the next morning
on Fox and Friends by Pete Hegseth or Ainsley
Earhart, what they should believe about what took
place. And you can expect that they are going to
say, because they're already sort of saying it.
These hearings are a distraction. Well, from what?
The hearings are a distraction from the real
stories. BIDEN Inflation. BIDEN Gas prices.
BIDEN Formula shortage, the Biden failure in
Ukraine. But you know, what is it, the audit
going on in whatever state, there's even still
an audit going on. And so at the end of the day,
the core question we care about is what might
come from the hearings? The hope would be just
obvious overwhelming evidence of criminality that
the Justice Department can't ignore. The dream
scenario would be what is presented in primetime
for everybody who wants to see it. To see
is so undeniably criminal in what it exposes that
the DOJ has to take it up. That's the dream. And
that's what we talked about earlier in the context
of former Attorney General Eric Holder saying
that's what he expects. Not everybody is expecting
that, but that's what Eric Holder expects